are you seeing the breaking news on Elon  and Twitter yeah it's official it's not  only is it official but it says uh Elon  just 17 minutes ago Elon has closed the  deal and fired the CEO and CFO gone come  on ring that bell ring the bell  let's go  Alleluia you know what we say to that  hey  goodbye and they fired vagina yes right  gone who was response personally  responsible spending we got it we got it  we got it right here check it out from  the Washington uh this is uh uh Jorge  vanilla posting he did it Elon Musk  fired the CEO CFO and censor in Chief  they say CEO parag agrawal Chief  Financial Officer Ned Segal and Vijaya  got a head of legal policy trust and  safety were all fired according to the  people Elon